thank you
[Music]
and in some good old Florida news I love
Florida the Tampa police chief has
resigned
why is that good after dodging a traffic
ticket
oh so she uh used her position to escape
a ticket during a traffic stop involving
her golf cart driven by her husband oh
[ __ ]
and I didn't know that this is the
result but my thing my thing is
I'm gonna need to do more than that to
get out right I wouldn't be crazy about
it okay if I had like 10 000 pounds of
heroin yeah all right I'm out of the
department yeah yeah but a golf cart
that's why I was like surprised I'm
surprised to see that she's residing
over that [ __ ] because there was video
of it yeah what was he doing I think I
think he was drunk her husband was drunk
right and then the cop was just like yo
what the [ __ ] and so and then there were
so much the issue the issue is more like
the idealisms of it because in the video
she's straight up saying like hey I'm
the police chief like yeah you'll be
okay here yeah oh she's using her power
today which is like kind of [ __ ] up
but you wouldn't expect her to resign I
think you should be allowed to do that
because they do that all the [ __ ]
time that's why I'm like but but there's
always that one rookie [ __ ] cop
that's like I'm gonna be the hero this
time I'm not gonna play your shenanigan
games I'm not a part of your stupid club
and then he just said like John you're
going in 10 40 something I've got a
drunk [ __ ] over here
yeah 10 45 not 10 44 10 45 she's a drunk
[ __ ] yeah oh the guy the operator uh oh
yeah I found it all right cool
he's like lost I don't see 10 45 oh [ __ ]
yeah we do Drunk [ __ ] who would have
thought I'm sending them over right now
give me the new coach there crazy turn
of events man so Mary O'Connor submitted
her resignation after an internal
affairs review found she violated Police
Department policy during a November 12th
stop by uh Pinas County Sheriff's deputy
during that stop which was recorded on
video by the deputy's body camera
O'Connor identified identified
identified herself who can't we now dude
and said I'm hoping you will let us go
tonight the deputy issued only a verbal
warning instead of a citation according
to the internal affairs review the golf
cart did not have a license tag a
requirement for when such vehicles are
driven on public streets O'Connor's
husband Keith said that they had just
come from a restaurant and didn't
usually Drive the cart on the streets so
the internal review found O'Connor
violated regulations on standards of
conduct and abuse of position or
identification
I think you let her go noon let her free
letter free as in like she doesn't have
to resign yeah dude give a mouse a
cookie what's the rest of her track
record did she put away the [ __ ] mob
that's true like if she's a gangster ass
cop that did some dope [ __ ] [ __ ] it but
if she's a [ __ ]
Drunk [ __ ] her whole life then or is
this another argument to be like see
this is why you don't let ladies become
police officers oh [ __ ] what you're
saying Anthony that's what he said
and then corrupt people are trying to
get her out so they need any excuses
possible so a second she does one thing
wrong you know what I mean it seems like
a pretty small thing for her to resign
because you're telling me cops don't get
their homies off tickets dude always
that's the and I have friends that are
cops so I want them to be able to get me
off tickets let it slide see I changed
she has too much Shame Shame is yeah
they can't take shame they'll take
embarrassment but not like no I'm too
ashamed of myself the fact they released
that video is pretty harsh and she's
making a lot of money well because like
there's actual it's like her in the
video saying straight up it's not like a
report it's like it's a video going
around of her going hey so I'm this
person and it's going viral well I think
that's what it is it looks yeah when
it's like that blunt of like someone
using their power to get out of
something what else hasn't she done
before uh yeah did she take down the
floor to Mom [ __ ] like or just if a
video gets publicized in such a dick
like a very direct piece of evidence
that everybody can tangibly hold on to
it's like then you maybe have to follow
the rules oh wait don't they get isn't
this position voted
right like I know the sheriff is sheriff
is not police chief though oh it's not
because I was thinking that maybe it was
a preemptive move because she was like I
ain't gonna win the second one so it's
like yeah I know what you mean like I
remember I spoke up to like a when I was
a dishwasher how they did the codes all
wrong the health codes and I spoke up
and all this [ __ ] everybody was yeah
[ __ ] his shoes all the biceps yes
he's fighting for us like you know I had
them all riled up and then they got me
because I was late one time they're like
that's it we had enough and I was like
really but they use one little thing to
get me that's how they get you they
broke the revolution because I [ __ ]
smoke up yeah you know they knew who the
ringleader was yeah Cesar Chavez the
sanitizer in the [ __ ] sink and they
mixed it up in order it was the
chemicals man
I got them I can see from his left eye a
resignation still her choice so it makes
it interesting I wonder what was on the
other side for her like a force
resignation that's what I'm saying like
I wonder what was the other hand for her
to go you know yeah I'm gonna resign I
don't want this to happen yeah be like
what's the other retirement would have
been sweet if she just resigned right
now but if she stayed on it could have
been like yeah yeah maybe so many
politics if there's a video of her crazy
huh
guys this is crazy
this is [ __ ] crazy
but [ __ ] politics huh
I don't know dude I tried caring for
this lady but I just don't give a [ __ ]
I gun car how about this white lady
leaving her [ __ ] she couldn't drive a
car why are they driving a golfer they
all got golf carts out there that's also
like unfortunately obnoxious though that
like that you know what I mean I think
this guy's rest of his career is gonna
suck ass like all the higher oh it's the
[ __ ] police chief oh [ __ ] be careful
you know yeah yeah [ __ ] too you're gonna
give us so much [ __ ] dude that sucks if
you're that guy though and you run into
that situation and you think the police
is testing you we're like are you gonna
follow the book and give me a ticket
yeah like you're supposed to it's not
what happened to that that cop in L.A
the Garner guy that killed everybody all
the cops all the black guys
there's some shitty what's his name Eric
what Eric Gardner yeah that was crazy
remember this [ __ ] you had a whole
Manifesto right dude how is that not a
movie yeah
try to put a cop in jail because he's
saying that the system's all rigged and
this and that and the judge said yeah
[ __ ] no dude [ __ ] not guilty type of
[ __ ] and he said all right I tried doing
the right way I try to [ __ ] out it
out in the best way possible all right
dude then he made a list right and she
started taking people out that's crazy
that's a wild [ __ ] he's the Punisher
dude daughter and all this [ __ ]
oh did he start getting some corrupt
cops do yeah he was killing all the
corrupt cops and all the [ __ ]
families huh and the [ __ ] daughters
and shoes wrote them off like oh a
lunatic crazy guy in the loose is he
though that's what they said is it
[ __ ] weird I know it is it is heavy
[ __ ] guys this is [ __ ] crazy
oh dude I would hate to be in trouble in
a scary situation with that girl okay
dude it's [ __ ] crazy we're in the
middle
yeah that's the black guy that got
killed who's who's his name no no isn't
it dude the whole time I'm like yeah
okay
who is it he had a Manifesto in here
regardless the dude that got killed
outside the [ __ ] yeah Garner that
[ __ ] was wild yeah
LAPD who beginning on February 3rd
committed a series of shootings OC blah
blah blah I was kind of rooting for him
you know how much like how corrupt it is
and it's so hard for people to speak up
because it is a giant fraternity so to
see someone that's like and the way he
wrote I think he wrote like uh he out at
everybody it was almost like what's that
movie The Rock
no no no I think you're talking about uh
oh no you want to talk about the rock
with Nicholas Cage yeah that was the
army guy who was kind of like yeah so he
was writing it was like [ __ ] yeah that
way like hey I'm like Navy SEAL train
blah blah blah blah I can tell you what
tactics you're gonna use even before you
use so he was laying out the battle plan
like if you guys do this I'm gonna do
this you guys are trying to come in
through the back I'm gonna have I'm
gonna meet you with this and it just
sounded so like oh [ __ ] and then he
ended up being in a cabin and it was
very very unsatisfying yeah because at
the very end it was just like I you seem
so like good you know that's every
[ __ ] time I play Grand Theft Auto I'm
all I was [ __ ] a bang bang and I get
cornered in this little [ __ ] spot and
I get killed I'm like God damn it that's
what it reminded me of yeah week yeah
you gotta bring the chopper in the slide
out [ __ ] you know he was definitely
five stars dude that guy was [ __ ]
five stars for sure so basically how it
started was in 2007 Dorner and Evans
responded to the DoubleTree Hotel in San
Pedro regarding a disturbance being
caused by a Christopher getler who had
schizophrenia and severe dementia during
her father report alleging that his
partner Evans had used excessive force
in her treatment of gettler accusing her
of twice kicking Gatlin in the chest and
once in the face while he was handcuffed
and lying on the ground yeah so he read
on his own partner uh it was his
training officer apparently gatherer's
father testified that his son told him
he had been kicked by the police officer
Dorner father reported the day after
being told that Evans had been given an
evaluation saying that he needed to
improve his performance which that
basically was the thing that tumbled
everything else LAPD invest see the
complaint examining the allegation
against Evans and the truthfulness of
during his report through an internal
View Board of three members two LAPD
captains and a criminal defense attorney
during the seven-month investigation of
joyner's complaint Evans was assigned to
a death Duty and was not allowed to earn
money outside of her LAPD job during his
attorney at the board hearing was former
LAPD Captain around Quan blah blah
um
termination failed appeal torner was
fired by the LAPD for making false
statements in his report and his
testimony against Evans
okay okay judge okay you gonna see it's
[ __ ] crazy imagine that's why he
talks okay okay all right whatever all
right are we done cause I'm done okay
I'm done
I know like yeah whatever okay whatever
okay do that thing or slam the thing
already I'm done I'm so done
foreign
[Music]
[Music]